vamos a resolver otra integral triple y
en esta ocasión no voy a evaluar la
integral lo que vamos a hacer es definir
la integral triple de manera similar a
como lo hicimos en el vídeo anterior en
el segundo vídeo en donde encontramos la
masa usando la densidad pero lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es mostrarles
cómo calcular los límites cuando éstos
son un poquito más complicados y también
cómo cambiar el orden de la integración
así que vamos a decir que yo tengo la
superficie esto lo estoy inventando 2 x
+ 3 z +
que todo esto es igual a 6
vamos a dibujar esa superficie voy a
comenzar haciendo mis ejes coordenadas
mi eje x mi eje z y mi eje g
les pongo sus flechitas y sus etiquetas
x y z
y voy a tener esa superficie en el
octante positivo ya que cuando estamos
hablando de tres dimensiones no tenemos
cuatro cuadrantes sino 8 oct antes y nos
interesa bastante en el que tanto la
equis la aie y las citas son positivos o
que cuál es el punto en x cuando jay z
son 0 2x va a ser igual a 6 por lo tanto
x va a ser igual a 6 entre 2 3 1 2 3
aquí va a estar la x el punto en que es
cuando los otros dos ejes van a estar en
cero por lo tanto va a ser igual a 6 1 2
3 4 5 6
y finalmente el punto en zetas cuando x
son igual a 0 3 z va a ser igual a 6 por
lo que aceptan 603 va a ser igual a 2
así que la superficie que me interesa va
a lucir así más o menos a este plano
inclinado una superficie inclinada uno
de este otro punto y estos dos los
unimos al final
esta es la superficie definida por esta
función y digamos que me interesa el
volumen y lo voy a hacer aquí un poco
más complicado porque podríamos decir
bueno es el volumen entre estas
superficies el volumen que me interesa
es lo que está por encima de esta
superficie hasta el valor de 7 igualados
así que el volumen que nos interesa
va a lucir un más o menos así
vamos a ver si podemos dibujar lo voy a
proyectar el valor requiere y hasta el
punto de zeta igualados
más o menos
voy a poner la parte de arriba en otro
color diferente para que se distinga así
que esto es entre el plano detalle
y ahora voy con
aquí es más o menos en este
en este punto esta es la parte más
difícil hacer el dibujo de estos
segmentos
así que esto es la línea que está en el
plano x z y tenemos otra línea que
conecta estos dos puntos este triángulo
verde es parte del plano al que le
quiero encontrar el volumen y lo que
podemos hacer es notar que el volumen
que nos interesa es el que se encuentra
entre este triángulo amarillo y el
triángulo verde va a ser el volumen
entre ellos vamos a ver si lo podemos
hacer un poquito más claro porque aquí
la visualización quizás está un poquito
difícil aquí tenemos un muro frontal que
lo voy a dibujar en magenta y la pared
de atrás va a ser estar
esto de aquí y aquí hay otra pared y la
base de esto va a ser este plano de
nuestra función esto que estoy
subrayando aquí en rojito
bueno no sé si lo complique más haciendo
este dibujo pero bueno espero que hayan
captado la idea vamos a hacer nuestro
mejor intento así que si queremos sin
calcular el valor pero bueno pensándolo
bien si de todas maneras vamos a
trabajar con integrales triples pues por
qué no mejor calcular la masa de esto en
lugar del volumen y que además que tenga
una densidad variable así que digamos
que la densidad en este volumen que
acabamos de definir de x se está en ese
punto que puede hacer cualquier cosa
este no es el objetivo que les quiero
enseñar aquí va a ser x al cuadrado por
jay x zeta la primera cosa que yo quiero
hacer que quiero visualizar es ubicar un
pequeño cubo dentro de este volumen
vamos a hacerlo en un color que se note
si tuviera un cubo vamos a ponerlo aquí
este colorcito si yo tuviera un cubito
aquí
en el volumen que estoy considerando
este cubito lo consideran debe o la
diferencia en el volumen
dv es la diferencia de lo voy a poner
otro color en verde de iu
x la diferencial en x de x x la
diferencial en zeta receta y si queremos
la masa de este como vamos a multiplicar
la densidad por esta diferencial de
volumen
así que la masa de m vamos a abreviar la
diferencial de la masa
va a ser igual a esto x esto x cuadrado
ez x esto deje de x y de zeta
y normalmente obtenemos esto dependiendo
de que queremos integrar primero así que
tratemos de hacerlo vamos a hacerlo de
la manera tradicional en los vídeos
pasados integramos con respecto a z así
que vamos a hacerlo
si vamos a integrar con respecto a z
vamos a tomar este cubito y vamos a
sumar todos los cubos en el eje z los
que van arriba y abajo
así que si hacemos esto cuál va a ser el
límite inferior
bueno cuando sumamos estos cubitos de
arriba hacia abajo pues vamos a formar
una columna cuál va a ser la base de
esta columna pues va a estar en esta
superficie de la superficie definida por
esta función
si queremos esa base en términos de z
tenemos que resolver esto en términos de
z vamos a despejar z así que aquí
tenemos 3 z que es igual a 6 menos 2 x
menos g
por lo que se está va a ser igual a dos
menos dos tercios de x menos y entre
tres esto es exactamente lo mismo que
esto solamente que lo estamos definiendo
en términos de z y solo lo hemos
manipulado algebraica mente el límite de
abajo que lo pueden visualizar la base
de estas columnas que van de arriba a
abajo
todas estas columnas el límite inferior
va a ser esto la superficie en términos
de z es decir cuando z es igual a dos
menos dos tercios de x menos entre tres
y cuál es el límite superior bueno la
parte superior de las columnas va a ser
este plano en verde y qué es lo que
dijimos que era esto pues cuando z es
igual a 2
qué es este plano esta superficie que
estoy señalando acá donde se está es
igual a 2 y por supuesto cuál es el
volumen de esta columna puede va a ser
la función de densidad x cuadrada porque
por z multiplicado por la diferencia en
volumen pero primero vamos a integrar
con respecto acepta
y bueno vamos a ver ahora vamos a
integrar con respecto no sé en los
pasados vídeos integramos con respecto a
ye así que ahora vamos a integrar con
respecto a x vamos a poner aquí una de
equis así que ahora ya tenemos estas
columnas que al integrar con respecto a
z obtenemos el volumen de estas columnas
donde los límites superiores se
encuentran en el plano vamos a ver si lo
puedo dibujar aquí un poquito mejor el
límite superior es esta superficie verde
y el inferior es el plano que está
marcado por nuestra función definida
aquí arriba pero ahora vuelva a ser el
límite inferior con respecto a las x
bueno esta superficie está definida en
todo el camino hasta que x es igual a 0
y si se confundan ustedes con esto que
no es nada difícil cuando trabajamos en
tratando de imaginar cosas en tres
dimensiones ustedes pueden decir bueno
ya hemos integrado con respecto a z que
otras variables nos quedan con respecto
a xy ayer voy a dibujar
proyección de este volumen en el plano x
que de hecho esto ayuda a simplificar
las cosas así que permítanme aquí
redibujar los ejes vamos a rotar esto de
manera que nos quedan los ejes x y
llegué la manera tradicional en que
siempre los hemos visto dibujados les
ponemos sus flechitas aquí y aquí y sus
etiquetas x y ya y este punto de acá que
es bueno es es x igual a 3 así que lo
dibujamos en el eje 123 aquí está el 3 y
este punto es igual a 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 así
que en el eje x o mejor dicho en el
dominio xy esta es la proyección una
forma de analizar esto es que bueno
tenemos estas columnas que hemos
integrado en el eje de la seta de arriba
abajo pero cuando la estamos viendo
desde arriba mirando en la dirección del
plano xy cada una de las columnas va a
verse así
o la base de la columna se va a ver así
imaginando que esta columna va a salir
de sus pantallas hacia ustedes y la base
de esta columna va a tener una de equis
y una de ella aquí así que hemos
decidido integrar con respecto a x vamos
a agregar cada una de estas columnas en
la dirección x así que la pregunta era
cuál era el límite inferior o en el
límite inferior aquí es cuando x es
igual a 0 y si hubiera una línea acá
entonces sería esta línea como función
de g
definitivamente sería en función de ella
así que hacemos esta integral cuál es
nuestro límite inferior pues cuando x es
igual a 0 y nuestro límite superior
bueno nuestro límite superior está en
esta relación pero en términos de x
cuando z es igual a 0 y para encontrar
esto pues tenemos que ver esta línea en
esta función cuando se está es igual a
cero qué resultado nos da así que nos
queda 2 x más que igual a 6 y como
estamos integrando con respecto a x
entonces vamos a tener 2x igual
6 - james x igual a 3 menos de entre 2
así que nuestro límite superior va a ser
igual a x igual a 3 menos y entre 2 y
finalmente vamos a integrar con respecto
a que es la parte más fácil cuando
integramos con respecto a x hicimos esta
columna en toda esta línea que va a ser
la base de lo que integramos en la
dirección x ahora lo que vamos a hacer
es integrar en la dirección de jeff de
arriba a abajo con respecto a y así que
cuál es el límite inferior de iu y es
igual a 0 y el límite superior ese es
muy sencillo es igual a 6 y aquí ya lo
tienen está lista la integral triple
para que suframos resolviendo la pero no
lo haremos en este vídeo ya que me he
quedado sin tiempo y no quiero que
rechacen este vídeo así que lo dejamos
acá nos vemos después